in that previous episode the killer
kills only in the fall when there was
plenty of rain it could be that he puts
them in some sort of well or tank that
is open to the skies and that fills up a
brain water the more it rains the less
time the victim has to lose job where do
you work Nathaniel you have a job my
sole occupation is praying to the
all-merciful Lord for the salvation of
humanity you are the anti cost father
how's that again battle chrissakes shoot
I shot him well are you ready to show
your courage in order to save your son
do it [ __ ] hi Wayne and drive again via
tragic 5-mile I accept Edwin for Sean's
sake I have no choice left damn
ouch ooh whoa
your record is indeed popcorn yo Ethan
oh go home read my name it back let's
get off this motorbike sing sing a
looper there we go
tough girl I have digged it how'd they
get it
how'd you get it do all right what are
we gonna do
let's check in shall we
so the light Oh that ass should really
have the data it's pixels it's always
good to say all right that's the restore
isn't nice oh yeah all right how could I
do that
um get off my face I'd like a room
vestigators trying to find are you
nodding oh yeah
stop it feeling the register all right
let's filling this thing seriously what
the [ __ ] Mazen page 20 thing go how long
will you be staying with us moves page I
don't know yet room 201 last floor
stairs on the right didn't the court
here sirs on the right and the court
thank thanks okay
the pleasure was all mine that's for
sure that's for shizzle my nizzle little
pretzel and bi no no not back the
controls are awful all right let's get
up the stairs
and then to the right
that obnoxious receptionist better not
have a spare key to my room yeah a lot
of it leaves me to sweat all right
my room was 201 stairs on the right last
four
Oh last floor why don't you say that
Madison no 201 visit stairs on it oh
[ __ ] me that was annoying all right huh
is that Ethan okay
I'll guess they'll finally erect sir
whoa are you all right what's he doing
there
oh yeah after the car thing
no I'm go haha you're badly hurt Rita I
need you girl please just help me to my
room it's number two's like god dammit I
gotta find now their room now all right
come here Ethan I'll suck no I'll what
all right let's go
I just gotta be - OH - right 205 the
[ __ ] logic have you got the key thing
yep
all right let me just open that la ba ba
ba ba that's how I open does
ooh what's up you're really in bad shape
you should see a doctor you must have
one maybe two broken ribs it's not fatal
oh but it's sore as hell don't worry
about it
broken ribs ain't kill number head is
bleeding it looks deep ah
all right let me see if I can patch you
up all right
gotta [ __ ] heal everyone is game all
right let's take all of this I should
disinfect his cuts all right all righty
Ethan what's the name drink this drink
it Oh
I mean I'm gonna disinfect your wound
this might hurt a little and uh just
kidding
ha ha ha ha
sorry sorry you okay all right and a
little Jake stop being a [ __ ] I'll try
to be more careful uh John Todd and then
yeah
and uh yes and so so dad down there at
least it won't get infected
Thanks you want anything else do ya
anything else he's in trouble I can't
just walk away and leave it like that I
really didn't do it either
I'll help him first and ask questions
later what else do you need bandages sky
so annoying all right
para kamal painkiller administer in
cases of intense pain do not take more
than one pill every time I should begin
intense pain in sight what you haven't
they just leave these in hotel rooms
take this it should be noted it's a
painkiller he'll help reduce the pain
it says on the box to take one every 24
hours I don't think it's a good idea to
exceed the dose dodd town may want to do
a woman i can't afford to wait I
wouldn't move around for a few days if I
were you I I'm gonna take you out if you
want to come me again
all right let me help you oh oh all
right diggity diggity I see that move
that's the oldest move in the book oh
I'm too broken too
I'll wait here to shower on my own let
me know if you need anything
well isn't he's polite whoo he's not
even closing the door ah that's the
second oldest moving the book
hello hello talk to me that way I'll
know if you pass out what's your name uh
Madison Madison are you staying in the
hotel
yeah a bit saamne no I live in town I
suffer from chronic insomnia being in
the shower sleep in motels don't ask me
why
whenever I get too exhausted I I come
and spend a night here
does that make sense I'm I'm just
passing through
and what else do you do Madison par from
fixing up strangers hi I'm a
photographer I take pictures of
furniture for fashionable design Mac it
sounds like a lie
and you I know your night
all right Oh got away forever
all right that began thanks for staying
I feel a lot bad to hear bra
okay
I better get going Madison
you show me your tips of yuan I already
seen them hahahaha
the way you never told me your name
Ethan be careful Ethan fine I'll be
careful
I'll be careful just kidding I got to
start saving my son actually alright we
put it under here and then we a bath or
a better thought Lois I don't know okay
let's get to mission number two I think
this is my favorite mission out of all
of these which one is this
and
are you prepared to suffer to save your
son
I just suffer like a come to the old
power plant all right that is not my
favorite at all I hate this one
but hey watch can you down let's go
I don't know if it will still play
Thiessen though we might cut to someone
else
yep yep yep
but but but I'm bad I don't know what
I'm doing I'm sorry I'm not sorry haha
sorry okay I'm really sorry all right
let's go
what are we doing he's really fat look
at the car except DSP I really don't
like you you know that right
was that the first time yeah I have a
killer guy first time you killed
somebody
no can answer this
it always does something to you the
first time I guess that it's then you
get used to it I'll be since there I'm
not sure I want to get used to it
all right what's going on here that's
him oh I remember this ha ha
it took my while all right this is
awesome here's lap kurta primeras young
lieutenant Carter Blake I'd like to ask
you some questions
no one gives a [ __ ] about the rain in
this town oh no whoa no he didn't
[ __ ] don't just stand there he's gonna
get away left I guess uh I gotta follow
him klappa klappa I play forever I know
touchin my guts Lefty back off [ __ ]
touch her boob ha ha
double play Oh flowers man watching my
am left that was a right [ __ ] circle
can't see anything
good XXXI Vegas I don't throw a pass at
me brah I know I missed one blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah sound really
sorry really sorry about the bone up
[ __ ] down no hey hey oh no [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Oh got it what is he doing what is he
doing I missed one
Oh squids grow their squid don't don't
check it out man
yeah
oh no the chickens anything about the
check ads Oh No left what the hell
happened
oh [ __ ] it's another memorable scene in
this game that game has a lot of
memorable scenes ah what am i doing
we got to go in here thank you
ah come out mr. origami Keller
come out you little pig see what I did
there
not me neither Oh st are you over here
pig is humping me I don't like this
what ha miss me [ __ ]
no Dan I'll brew nice what [ __ ] I gotta
get this guy super focused peer tape
nice block oh yeah um God have Clemmie
epic blocker
oh I'll hit anyway ah fatality ha ha ha
that's how I roll this time it looks
like we got our origami kill really
gonna end this episode here it's a
little shorter than the other ones but
hey my internet is really slow so it's
just for a couple days I need shorter
videos otherwise they won't upload
anyway sales numbers love you
you